after the crackdown in 1989 you know the
Chinese government has sort of spun its
version of events you know what really
happened what was that that movement all
about and you know this is 20 years ago
this is this is a whole generation so
they're they're you know a lot of a lot
of you know young Chinese people who
don't really know the truth about what
happened then and and the truth as as
JAL describes it is this was not a
protest movement that threatened the
state that threatened order in fact it
was it was almost entirely peaceful that
the the people who participated they had
various reasons for taking part but they
were idealistic you know the government
but what what what jazz book makes clear
is there was somebody of the highest
levels in fact the highest level who
really saw another way who really saw
that that we did not need to crack down
on this movement that there was an
energy that was about making China a
better place helping China's reforms
continue and people trying to don't
realize that you know the the line that
they're fed now is that there was a
rebellion there were some bad people who
were manipulating it it had to be put
down any reasonable government would do
the same thing if there was a rebellion
in their capital and the truth is you
know there wasn't a rebellion until the
government sent troops in and brought
everybody in Beijing out on the streets
in a kind of state of agitated concern
and you know at that point they had
something they had a lot of people who
were fighting them and they shot their
way through the city and shot their way
into into Tiananmen Square so I think
it's important to tell the truth about
what happened to Tiananmen but more
importantly you know Jiao talks about
the need in China for I mean he for a
democratic system you know what he talks
about is a kind of Western parliamentary
system this is this is then no longer
about history I mean this this then
enters the dialogue that that concern
Chinese people are having all the time
about what is the future of China what
is China need to be I mean the the deal
that the government is offering them is
we will let you get rich but we will not
give you any political freedom and if
you challenge the state if you challenge
the Communist Party
you may be arrested you may be
disappeared so I think what this book is
showing is that is that you know at this
high level there are people who are
thinking about another way and where
where political freedom can not only
assist in economic development but is
valuable for society that's own right
and that this our this through this book
you know this line of thinking from an
interesting person forgotten until now
he is now entering the dialogue and you
know who knows who knows how it will
affect that dialogue
ciao you know the the one of the one of
the reasons that things got worse I
think is when the student movement
really broke out Joe was in North Korea
there was a long-standing state visit
he felt he couldn't cancel it so so he
was kind of out of the decision-making
at a very crucial point and this
movement would have I think died out
pretty quickly but when students first
started to march remember they started
to march after the death of whoo-yah
bong who had been party general
secretary until being purged a couple
years earlier and Cleo bong wasn't the
most charismatic figure in the world but
but he was a relative liberal he was
sort of real he had a heart that a lot
of a lot of these Communist Party
officials served don't show and so when
he died the students used him as a
symbol to kind of express their
discontent with a lot of things
including the general level of political
freedom I really think this would have
died down relatively quickly had the
government not made a very unfortunate
decision of printing a very scary
editorial in the official mouthpiece
people's daily that branded this student
movement as unpatriotic as
counter-revolutionary you know terms
that that are very charged in China and
we're basically telling these students
who felt idealistic who felt that they
were keeping up a tradition of marching
and protesting in the interests of
Chinese society it had the effect it was
very disappointing and was was taken as
a challenge and so the day after this
editorial which was meant to intimidate
them and get this thing over with the
day after you know suddenly everything
escalated and the biggest protest to
date erupted the next day and so so when
Zhao came back from North Korea he was
basically saying look it was this
editorial that made things worse let's
back away from it let's find a way from
it I'll even take responsibility for it
it was my mistake but we need to back
away from this because you know it's
clearly made things worse now here you
have a problem with a non modern
political system basically the editorial
represented Deng Xiaoping think
don was the supreme leader of china then
he didn't even have a title but
everybody knew he was the leader so
there was a sense if you back down from
this editorial dunks campaign will lose
face well that argument played out all
the way to the end where rather than
have this octogenarian lose face
it's better to unleash the troops send
the tanks into tenement square kill
hundreds of people because the
alternative would be a loss of face I
mean I'm simplifying a little bit but in
a sense that was where the the battle
lines were drawn internally and where
Joe thought we can back down and let me
even take the fall for this and where
the party wouldn't wouldn't allow that
to happen
initially we all called the protest sort
of pro-democracy protests it was kind of
an easy shorthand it was kind of a
backlash I think in in analysis of it
and people said well I wasn't about
democracy and and you know these kids
didn't know what they wanted and people
were out there for various reasons I
think that misses the point basically
they were they were out there because
they didn't like the system I mean it's
not unlike the protests in Iran right
now you know do people want to overthrow
the state do they know what they want as
an alternative not necessarily but they
know they're not happy with this the way
this elections going with the state of
things and that to me that's essentially
a democracy movement that people are
saying we want a better system we want
we want a better political system so so
you know it was a little bit chaotic
people were talking about democracy they
were talking about fighting corruption
they were talking about some smaller
concerns that they had but you know did
I think Joe did understand the kind of
mixed message you know he thought there
was a way to take a softer line to
compromise and to essentially harness
this energy for the good of China and
not to deal it as a threat to the state
you know that the turning point was was
was you know the hardliners wanted to
basically bring in the army to clear the
protesters and Joe Joe said I can't do
that and that's one you know in a
communist state you can have vigorous
debate behind the scenes but the sort of
process the the the idea of democratic
centralism once there's a decision
everybody serve lines up and supports it
judges said I can't do that I'm not
going to be the general secretary who
authorizes lethal force against this
protest movement and at that point he
was out and you know that was maybe two
weeks before the tenement massacre
actually happened but you know he he
just refused to go along and that was
that was it for him that was it for his
career and the die was cast that the
army was going to come in it was just a
question of when
I think everyone I mean the memory of
what happened 20 years ago
I think people all around the world I
mean they were they were caught up in
the idealism you know CNN it was one of
the first things CNN was sort of
broadcasting daily into our homes you
know from there they were broadcasting
live from tenement square when they were
when they were able to at first it
really captured the imagination but I
think even in in even overseas in
people's minds I think people forget
whether whether the crackdown eventually
was justified had it gotten out of
control had to become violent was the
state not functioning because of it and
I think the book makes it clear that
this is a this is a peaceful
demonstration an idealistic peaceful
demonstration that that could have been
handled better and more than that what
you realize from the book is that that
the the debate then is still the debate
now I mean this is twenty years ago but
essentially it's the same China that yes
you've had economic liberalisation it's
been successful but political reform has
to follow for a healthy society and that
was the debate then and Jiao Jiao was a
relative liberal in that in that debate
he'd lost that's still unresolved and
that that it's not going to just
disappear it's going to it's going to
bubble up from time to time and I and I
actually think this this book and jazz
argument will now become part of that